yes yes mark ruffalo is no longer the
only hulk and we are excited about it
how's it feel about going green come on
it's so much fun and mark taught me a
lot i have to say just watching him play
that character seeing him transform
seeing him find you know work on the
voice and all of that was just so
exciting i think i'm jealous is that
what i'm feeling
and my character
has zero issue with turning into a hulk
she sort of does it seamlessly so it has
none of the like angst around it which
is except that she doesn't want to be a
superhero you could be an avenger oh i'm
not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
she-hulk attorney outlaw is the mcu's
first half-hour comedy series orphan
black's tatiana maslany plays a lawyer
who transforms into a six foot seven
super powered hulk the good places
jamila jamil and ginger gonzaga co-star
women are the driving force behind the
series that debuts august 17th on disney
plus
yeah it feels really good to have
so many women in front of the camera and
behind the camera in control in power
having their opinions heard all the way
down to having so many women like
producers filmmakers actresses and we
have so much diversity on our show can
we get some shots please it's an
emergency this thing's funny like really
funny
yeah it's like goofy it's like a person
who doesn't want to like have to be
tugged into this role that the whole
world has thrown at them and just wants
to be good at swipe dating but it's hard
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
[Music]